where some considerable time ago we were
discussing my idea new at the time
uh for Constructor Theory
which
was and is uh an idea I had for
generalizing the quantum theory of
computation
uh to cover not just computation but all
physical processes
and I guessed and still guess that this
is going to be this is going to provide
a new mode of description of
um physical systems and laws of physics
um and also new laws of its own which
will be deeper than any than the deepest
existing theories of which the deepest
are quantum theory and relativity
and at the time I was I was all
enthusiastic about this and
um
uh what intervened between then and now
is that
writing a book took much longer than I
expected but now I'm back to it and
we're working on Constructor Theory and
if anything I would say it's fulfilling
its promise more than I expected and
sooner than I expected
um given how we're working on it
uh
one of the first rather unexpected
yields of this theory has been
a new foundation for information Theory
there's a there's a notorious problem
with defining information within physics
namely that on the one hand information
is purely abstract and the the original
theory of computation as developed by
Alan Turing and others regarded
computers and the information they
manipulate purely abstractly as
mathematical objects many mathematicians
to this day don't realize that
information is physical and that
computers there is no such thing as an
abstract computer only a physical object
can compute things
um and on the other hand physicists have
always known that in order to do the
work that the theory of information does
within physics such as uh uh informing
the theory of statistical mechanics and
thereby thermodynamics the second law of
thermodynamics
information has to be a physical
quantity and yet
its information is independent of the
physical object that it resides in so
I'm speaking to you now information
starts as
some kind of electrochemical signals in
my brain and then it gets converted into
other signals in my nerves and then into
sound waves and then into the vibrations
of a of a microphone mechanical
vibrations then into electricity and so
on
and presumably will eventually go on the
internet and so this something has been
instantiated in radically different
physical objects which obey different
laws of physics and and so on and and
yet in order to describe this process to
say what has happened during this
process you have to refer to the thing
that has remained constant throughout
the process which is only the
information rather than any physical
thing like energy momentum and so on
the way to get this substrate
independence of information
is to refer it to a level of physics
that is below and more fundamental than
things like laws of motion that we have
been used to in the past thinking
thinking of as near near the the lowest
most fundamental level of physics and
that's what constructive theory is it's
a level of description
of physics physical laws and physical
systems that
is more fundamental than than the
existing
uh prevailing conception of what physics
is namely uh particles and waves and
space and time and an initial State and
laws of motion that describe the
evolution of that initial State what led
to this hope or this this kind of way of
hoping that
um there will be a this new kind of
foundation for uh the laws of physics
was really the the quantum theory of
computation
which uh at the time I had I had thought
for a while that the quantum theory of
computation is the whole of physics and
the reason why it seemed reasonable for
a while to think that was that
a universal quantum computer
um Can simulate any other finite
physical object with arbitrary accuracy
and that means that the set of all
possible motions which is computations
of a universal computer
corresponds to the set of all possible
motions of anything
so there is a certain sense in which
studying the universal quantum computer
is the same thing as studying every
other physical object it contains the
all the possible motions of all possible
physical objects within its own possible
diversity and so uh I used to say that
the quantum theory of computation is the
whole of physics because because of this
property
but then I realized that that isn't
quite true and there's a there's an
important Gap in that connection namely
although the quantum computer
uh can simulate any other object and can
sort of represent or be any other object
so that you can study any object via its
characteristic programs
what the quantum theory of computation
can't tell you is which program
corresponds to which physical object or
which physical system now this might
sound like a inessential
technicality but it's actually of
fundamental importance because
uh
it's it's uh not knowing which which
abstraction in the computer corresponds
to Which object is a little bit like
having a bank account and them telling
you oh the your your balance is some
number
uh unless you know what number it is you
haven't really expressed uh the whole of
physics the whole of the physical
situation of of you and your bank
account and similarly if you're only
told that your physical system
corresponds to some program of the of
the quantum computer then you have and
you haven't said which then you haven't
specified the whole of physics so then I
thought well what we need is a
generalization
of
the quantum theory of computation that
does say that that that that
assigns to each program
the the corresponding real object
now that was that was an early
conception of the quantum theory of the
sorry of of uh constructive theory
um making it directly a generalization
of the theory of computation but then I
realized and I had already realized this
at the time
um that
um
that's not the way to go because that
still tries to cast construct a theory
within the same mold as all existing
theories and therefore it wouldn't solve
this problem of providing an underlying
framework it still would mean that just
as a program
has an initial State and then laws of
motion that is the laws of the operation
of the computer and then a final state
which is the output of the computer so
uh that way of looking at Constructor
Theory would have made
um would have
simply been a translation of
existing physics it wouldn't have
provided anything new
the new thing which I think is the key
to
uh the fact that Constructor Theory uh
delivers new content
um was that the laws of constructive
theory are not about
an initial state laws of motion final
state or anything like that
they are
um um
they are just about which such
Transformations are possible and which
are impossible and the the laws of
motion and that kind of thing are sort
of indirect remote consequences in some
cases of just saying what's possible and
what's impossible and also
that the laws of constructive theory
are not about
The Constructor they're not about how
you do it only whether you can do it and
this is by the way this is analogist in
theory of computation the theory of
computation isn't about
transistors and and uh wires and input
output devices and so on it's about
which transformations of information
are possible and which aren't possible
and because we have Universal computer
we know that the possible ones
correspond to a program for a universal
computer but the universal computer you
can make in lots of different ways
that's in essential to
the Deep laws of computation similarly
in the case of Constructor Theory
what's important is which
transformations of physical objects are
possible and which are impossible
when they're possible you'll be able to
do them in lots of different ways
usually you'll be able to achieve them
in lots of different ways when they're
impossible
that will always be because some law of
physics
forbids them and that is why as alcohol
said
the content of physical theories of any
scientific theory is in what it forbids
and also in how it explains what it
forbids and similarly if you have this
theory of what is possible and what is
impossible it implicitly tells you what
all the laws of physics are
and that
um
basis very simple basis
is proving very fruitful already and I
have great hopes that that various
niggling problems and notorious
difficulties in existing existing
formulations of physics will be solved
by this single idea
May well take a lot of work to see how
but uh that that's what I expect and I'm
I think that's what we're beginning to
see
in some ways it's
it's uh this Theory
just like quantum theory and relativity
and and anything that's fundamental in
physics overlaps with philosophy
and uh
having the right philosophy which is the
philosophy of Carl Poppa basically
is although not essential it is
extremely helpful to avoid going down
blind alleys
so
um the popper I suppose is most famous
for his Criterion of demarcation between
science and metaphysics uh which uh
which is that scientific theories are
those that are in principle testable by
experiment and what he called measure
physical theories I think would be
better called philosophical theories are
the ones that can't and this is often
misunderstood
um as claiming that only the scientific
theories are worth having now that as as
pop-up wants a remarked to John Hogan is
a silly interpretation for example
Popper's own theory is a philosophical
Theory and he certainly wasn't saying
that that was an illegitimate Theory
so uh Papa actually investigated in
great detail
what being tested being testable is not
um as simple a concept as it sounds and
he investigated in great detail and laid
down principles
um
which leads me to the question so in
what sense is
construct a theory testable
because
um if it's just uh uh constructive
theory consists of a language in which
to express other scientific theories
well that can't be true or false it can
only be convenient or inconvenient but
also laws but these laws are not about
physical objects they're laws about
other laws they say they say that other
laws have to obey constructive theoretic
principles
um now
um that
um raises the issue of how you can test
a law about laws because you know you if
it says that laws have to have such and
such a property you can't actually go
around and find a law that doesn't have
that property
um because
experiment could never tell you that
that law was true
well this fortunately this problem has
been solved by Papa and and uh you have
to go indirectly in the case of these
laws about laws which I I want to
introduce the standard terminology that
laws about laws should be called
principles like and that this is a lot
of people already use that kind of
terminology but
I'd rather make it standardized
that you talk about for example the
principle of the conservation of energy
which is a statement that all laws have
to respect the conservation energy
perhaps it's not obvious to you but
there is no experiment that would that
would show a violation of the
conservation of energy because if you
did if somebody presented you with an
object that produced more energy than it
took in you could always say ah well
that's due to an invisible thing or a
law of motion that's different from what
we think or maybe the formula for energy
is different for this object from what
we thought so there's no experiment that
could ever that could ever refute it and
in fact in the history of physics
uh the discovery of the neutrino was
made by exactly that method that it
appeared that the law of conservation of
energy was not
um of being obeyed in beta decay
and then uh the Pauli suggested that
maybe the energy was being carried off
by an invisible particle that you
couldn't detect
um well it turned out that he was right
but the way you have to test that is not
by doing an experiment on beta Decay
it's by seeing whether the theory the
law that says that the neutrino exists
is successful and independently testable
so it's it's the testability of the law
that the principal tells you about that
in effect provides the testibility of
the principle
um
one thing I I I think it's important to
stress about about constructive theory
it it when we when I say we want to
reformulate physics in terms of what can
and can't be done that sounds like a
retreat into operationalism or a retreat
into positivism or something you know
that we shouldn't worry about
The Constructor that is you know the
thing that does the the the thing but
only in the input and output and whether
they are compatible but actually that is
not how it works in Constructor Theory
Constructor theory is all about how it
comes about it just expresses this in a
different language and uh I'm not I'm
not that familiar with
um the
um a very popular idea of cybernetics
that it came about a few decades ago but
I wouldn't be surprised if
um those ideas which proved ultimately
or which proved at the time not to lead
anywhere were actually a
uh an early
um Avatar
of Constructor Theory and but if I'm
right we'll only be able to see that
with hindsight because
um some of the ideas of constructive
theory are really
um impossible to have
uh until you have the conceptual
framework that is post
quantum theory of computation where I.E
after the
um theory of computation has been
explicitly incorporated into physics not
just philosophically
and that's what the quantum interior of
computation did I'm not sure whether Von
Neumann used the phrase Constructor or
constructive theory for his theory of or
did he call it the universal Constructor
uh the the Von Neiman's work in the
1940s
um is another
place where constructive theory could be
thought to have its antecedents
um
Von Neumann was was interested in
different issues he was interested in
how living things can possibly exist
given what the laws of physics are
this was before DNA and before the DNA
mechanism was discovered he was
interested in issues of principle how uh
the existence of a self-replicating
object was even consistent with the laws
of physics as we know of them
um and so he realized that there was a
uh an underlying
um logic and underlying algebra
something like that in which one could
express this and show what what was
needed and he actually solved the
problem of uh of how a living thing
could possibly exist basically by by not
copy it he showed that it couldn't
possibly work by literally copying
itself it had to have within it
a a code a recipe a specification or
computer program as we would say today
uh specifying how to build it and and
therefore the the replica
self-replication process had to take
place in two stages and he did this all
before the DNA system was known but he
never got anywhere because well from my
from my perspective he never got
anywhere with constructive theory or
with realizing that this was all at the
foundations of physics rather than just
the foundations of biology because he
was stuck in this prevailing conception
of physics as being about initial
conditions laws of motion and final uh
state where where among other things you
have to include the Constructor in your
description of a system which means that
you don't see the laws
uh about the transformation for what
they are so he eventually he when he
found that he couldn't make a a
mathematical model of a living object by
writing it and writing down its
equations on a piece of paper he
resorted to simplifying the laws of
physics and then simplifying them again
and again and eventually invented the
whole field that we now call
um cellular automata
but which which is a very interesting
field but it it takes us away from real
physics because he abstracted away the
laws of physics what I want to do is to
go in the other direction
to integrate it with laws of physics but
not with laws of physics as they are now
but with the laws of physics that have
an underlying algebra that resembles
or is a generalization of the theory of
computation several strands LED towards
this and
um I I was sort of
um lucky enough to be placed in in more
than one of them
um I guess the main thing was that
starting with
Turing and then Rolf landauer who was a
lone voice in the 1960s saying that
computation is physics
that because the theory of computation
to this day is regarded by
mathematicians as as being about
abstractions rather than as being about
physics landauer realized that the
concept of a purely abstract computer
doesn't make sense and that compute the
theory of computation has to be a theory
of what physical objects can do to
information
uh
landauer
focused on
what
the laws of physics what restrictions
the laws of physics impose on what kinds
of computation can be done and
unfortunately that was the wrong way
around because as we later discovered
the most important thing about the
relationship of physics with computation
or the the most striking thing if not
the most important is that quantum
theory I.E the the deepest laws of
physics that we know
uh permit new modes of computation that
wouldn't be possible in classical
physics
so once you have established the quantum
theory of computation
you've you've then have you've got a
theory of computation that is wholly
within physics and it's then natural to
try to generalize that which is what I
wanted to do so that's one of the
directions
Von Neumann
wasn't motivated really by theoretical
biology rather than theoretical physics
uh but he too was
another thing that I think inhibited Von
Neumann from realizing that his theory
was
fundamental physics was that he had the
wrong idea about quantum theory he had
settled for and was one of the pioneers
of building
a sort of cop-out version of quantum
theory that made it into just an
operational Theory where you would use
quantum theory just to work out
predict the outcomes of experiments
rather than
Express the laws of how the outcomes
come about
and I think that was one of the reasons
why Von Neumann never thought of his own
Theory as being a generalization of
quantum theory
because he didn't really take quantum
theory seriously his his contribution to
quantum theory was to provide this uh
set of Von Neumann rules that allows you
to to use the theory in practice without
ever wondering what it means
uh I came from a slightly different
tradition of via Hugh Everett of
thinking that what and and Carl poppo uh
in their different ways both of them
uh insisted that scientific theories are
about what is really there when why
observations come about not just
predicting what the observations are and
therefore I couldn't be satisfied with
just an operational version of quantum
mechanics therefore I had to embrace the
Everett or many universes interpretation
of quantum mechanics
from the present point of view the key
thing about that is that it is a
realistic Theory as the philosophers say
that is it's a theory that purports to
describe what really happens rather than
just our experiences of what happens
once you think of quantum theory that
way it's only a very small step to
realizing that
the quantum first of all that the
quantum theory of computation which was
my earlier work and then the quantum
theory of computation is not sufficient
to provide the foundation for the whole
of physics so what's the rest well the
rest is constructed this what's needed
in Constructor theory is to
express it in terms that can be
integrated with the rest of physics
formulas equations and so on and it
looks as though the because only then
can it make contact with
um other scientific theories and it it
the principles of constructive theory
then constrain the laws of other other
theories which I call subsidiary
theories now uh the Constructor theory
is sort of the deepest Theory and
everything else is subsidiary to it
it constrains them and that then leads
to contact with experiment so the key
thing to do uh apart from
um
guessing what the actual laws are is to
find a way of expressing them and so the
the first item on the agenda really is
to set up a constructive theoretic
algebra that's that's an algebra in
which
you can do two things one is to express
any other scientific theory in those
terms
uh the the it's the analog in the
prevailing formulation of physics would
be something like differential equations
but in Constructor Theory it will be an
algebra
um and then to use that algebra also to
express the laws of constructed Theory
which won't involve that won't be
expressed in terms of subsidiary
theories they they will just
make assertions about subsidiary
theories so we're working on that that
algebra and
um it's um
conceptual jolt to think in terms of it
rather than in the in the terms that
have been traditional in physics for the
last few decades
so we
try and think what it means find
contradictions between different strands
of thought about what it means realize
that the algebra and the Expressions
that we write in the algebra doesn't
quite make sense change the algebra see
what that means and so on so it's a it's
a process of
sort of
doing maths doing algebra by working out
things interleaved with
trying to understand what those things
mean and this is this is really
um very much mirrors
how the pioneers of quantum theory
develop their Theory it was the same
thing and in fact one of the
formulations of quantum of quantum
theory namely Matrix algebra as invented
by Heisenberg and others uh
isn't based on on the differential
equation kind of Paradigm but is is more
algebraic and it it in fact is
can be seen as a precursor of
Constructor Theory
um uh the the
um the algebra
is
um well we haven't yet succeeded in in
making a viable algebra but even with
the
um rudimentary form of it that we have
now we have got some remarkable results
um and this was uh mainly done by Chiara
maletto who the student that I'm working
with
um which
um
uh
have almost magically provided a deeper
foundation for information Theory than
was possible within physics before like
like all fundamental theories
um it's difficult to
um predict
what effect they will have precisely
because they are going to change things
at a fundamental level but there is one
big thing that I'm pretty sure the
Constructor theoretic
way of looking at physics has to offer
our world view in terms of everyday life
and our lives and that is in terms of
optimism
um optimism in in my uh terminology
doesn't mean expecting that things will
turn out well all the time
it's this very specific thing and which
I think captures the the historicals of
philosophical
uh trend of of what optimism has meant
if you remove the nonsense
and that is
the optimistic view is that it's not
that problems will not occur but that
all problems and all Evils are caused by
lack of knowledge
and the converse of that is that all
Evils are soluble given the right
knowledge and and knowledge can be found
by the by the methods of conjecture
criticism and so on that we know uh is
the way of creating knowledge and this
is although this sounds very this sounds
like a statement at a very human level
because it's about knowledge and evils
and being able to do things and so on
it is directly linked with Constructor
Theory at the most fundamental level
because the fundamental dichotomy in
constructive theory in terms of which it
claims the whole of science is Formula
is to be formulated is the difference
between
transformations
that are possible and those that are
impossible and there isn't a third
possibility that's the thing it the
whole thing doesn't work if there's a
third possibility so
if
a a task a transformation is impossible
then Constructor Theory says it must be
because there's some law or physics that
makes it impossible
and conversely if there isn't a law of
physics that makes it impossible then
it's possible there is no third
possibility so
what does possible mean in the
overwhelming majority of cases
well some things are possible because
they happen spontaneously but the
overwhelming majority of cases of things
that are possible are possible because
the right knowledge embodied in the
right physical object would it make that
happen
so
the dichotomy is since the dichotomy is
between forbidden by the laws of physics
and possible with the right knowledge
and there isn't any other possibility
this tells us that all Evils are due to
lack of knowledge now I think this is
counter-intuitive it's it's uh contrary
to Conventional wisdom and it's contrary
to our
um intuitive or at least culturally
intuitive way of looking at the world I
mean I myself find myself
grasping for a third possibility you
know isn't there something which we
can't do even though there's no actual
law or physics that says we we we we
won't be able to do it well no there
can't be uh this is uh uh built into
construct a theory there's no way of
getting at getting around it and I think
once you've
seen that it's at the foundations of
physics it becomes more and more natural
it becomes more and more sort of
um
obvious in the sense of uh well it's
weird but but what else could it be I
mean it's rather like it's rather like
the intuitive shift that comes from
realizing that people in Australia
really are upside down
compared with us and they really are
down there through the Earth
you know one can know this
intellectually
but
to actually think in those terms is
takes an effort it's something that we
all learn at some point accept
intellectually at some point if we're
irrational
but then
to incorporate that into our world view
um
changes us it changes us because whole
swathes of Supernatural thinking are
made Impossible by truly realizing that
the people in Australia are upside down
and similarly whole swathes of
irrational thinking are made Impossible
by realizing that in the sense I've just
described there is no third possibility
between
being able to do it if we have the right
knowledge and being forbidden by the
laws of physics the um stereotype of how
new ideas get into fundamental science
is that somebody has the idea everyone
thinks they're crazy and eventually
they're Vindicated I don't think it
happens like that very often I mean
there are cases where it has happened
like that but I think that much more
often and this is my own experience when
I've had new ideas is that it's not that
people say you're crazy that can't be
true they say
yeah that's nice well done and then they
go off and ignore it
um
and then eventually
people say oh well maybe maybe it leads
to this and maybe it leads to that and
maybe it's worth working on maybe it's
fruitful and then eventually
um they they work more on it this has
happened to several of the things that
I've done and this is what I would
expect to happen with constructive
theory uh I haven't had anyone tell me
that this is crazy and it can't be right
um but I'm certainly in the Fate in the
stage of most people most physicists
saying well that's that's nice that's
interesting yeah well done and then they
go away and ignore it no one no one is
actually working on it at the moment
several of our colleagues have have
expressed uh
something between curiosity and
substantial interest
which will the needle will go up as soon
as we have results at the moment there's
no publication I've submitted a
philosophical paper which hasn't even
been published yet
when that comes out uh there it'll get a
wider readership people will understand
what it's about but physicists want
results in in philosophy you can write a
paper that just has hopes in it or
interpretations of things but in physics
you need results when we have our first
few papers that have results
I think that
an exponential process of people working
on it will begin if it's true
of course it might be that some of these
results are of the form it can't be true
well in which case it will end up as an
interesting footnote to the history of
physics so I I had to write the
philosophical paper first
because uh there's quite a lot of
philosophical Foundation to construct a
theory and to put that into a physics
paper would have simply made it too long
and to physicists too boring so I have
to write a thing that I can refer to it
says philosophical paper first
and then the next thing will be well the
next thing was going to be constructive
theory algebra which is the language and
showing how the the language and
formalism and showing how both alternate
laws and new Constructor theoretic laws
can be expressed but now it's it's
likely that the first paper on
Constructor Theory will be Constructor
theoretic information Theory because
it's yielded
um unexpectedly good results we're
talking about the foundations of physics
here so the question is whether the
theory is consistent whether it's
fruitful whether it leads to new
discoveries
these foundational theories
are
of interest to people who like
foundational theories but their
usefulness comes in their fruitfulness
later so the quantum theory is again a
very good example
almost nobody is actually interested in
quantum theory
but
um except a few people who work on the
foundations of quantum theory but
every but now uh several decades after
its discovery
um
everybody who works on microchips or
everyone who works on information or
cryptography or and so on
um has to use quantum mechanics
and and
everybody who wants to understand their
position in the universe you know what
we are
has to um has to take a view about what
quantum theory tells us about what we
are for example you have to take a view
about whether it's really true that we
exist in vast numbers of parallel copies
some of them slightly different some of
them are the same as as I think quantum
mechanics
uh in inevitably leads to or not but
there's no rational way of not taking a
position on that issue well although
apart from the
issue of optimism which is an
unexpectedly direct connection to the
everyday level we can't tell at the
moment what
construct a theory will tell us about
ourselves and our position in the
universe and what every reasonable
person should know until we work out
what the theory says which uh we can't
do until we work it out properly within
the context of the theory of times I'm
basically about
anything that's fundamental
so that's it's not confined to
fundamental physics but for me that's
what it all revolves around in the case
of constructive theory how this is going
to develop totally depends on what the
theory turns out to say and even more
fundamentally whether it turns out to be
true it if it turns out to be false that
that is that one cannot build a
foundation to physics via the in the
constructed theoretic way that will be
extremely interesting because that will
mean that
whole lines of argument that seem to
make it inevitable that we need a
constructive theory are actually wrong
and how lines of unification that seem
to connect different fields
don't connect them and yet therefore
they must be connected in some other way
because the truth of the world has to be
connected uh it if it turns out to be
wrong the chances are it will not be it
will be found to be wrong long before
it's falsified this again is the
typical way in scientific theories uh
what what gets the headlines is if you
do an experiment and and you predict a
certain particle and it doesn't appear
and then you're proved wrong but
actually the overwhelming majority of
scientific theories are proved wrong
long before they ever get tested they're
proved wrong by being internally
inconsistent or being inconsistent with
other theories that we believe to be
true or most often they're proved wrong
by not doing the job
of explanation that they were designed
to do so if you if you have a theory
that is supposed to for example uh
explain the second Northern Dynamics and
you know why there is irreversibility
when the fundamental laws of physics are
reversible and then you find by
analyzing this theory that it doesn't
actually do that then you don't have to
bother to test it because it's it it
doesn't address the problem that it was
designed to address
if Constructor Theory turns out to be
false it's I think it's overwhelmingly
likely that it'll be by that method that
it just doesn't do this unification job
or foundational job that it was designed
to do um turning out to be wrong is not
uh a disgrace you know it's it's it's
not like in politics where if you lose
the election then you've lost in in
science if your uh idea that looked
right turns out to be wrong you've
learned something
I want to just ask you about this whole
uh
your stick about explanation yes
it seems counter to
what the poets will tell you
uh oh I'm not so sure
yeah I don't know about that the theater
yeah the most important word is the next
word the two be said
he said theory of description Matters
Most
and pound
said that there there's description and
there's the village explainers you know
so it's I'm just interested in well I'm
I'm not aware of all that little
subculture you've described but you
haven't read by the way John Bro right
now
uh that that definitely should
um not as popular as
yeah
um
you know this is obviously what you've
been thinking about for years yes talk
about in that context without saying in
my book
yeah yeah yeah
I remember we'll put your book up yeah
yeah
um
so one of the central
uh philosophical motivations for why I
do fundamental physics
is that I am interested in
what the world is like that is uh not
just
the world of our observations what what
we see but what the the invisible world
the the invisible processes and objects
that bring about the visible because the
visible is only the tiny superficial uh
and parochial
uh sheen on top of the real reality and
the amazing thing about the world and
our place in it is that we can discover
the real reality we can discover what is
at the center of stars even though we've
never been there we can find out that
those
cold tiny objects in the sky that we
call stars are actually
million kilometer white hot gaseous
spheres now they don't look like that
they look like cold dots but we know
different we know that the invisible
reality
is there giving rise to our visible
perceptions now
that science has to be about that
is has been for many decades a minority
and unpopular view among philosophers
and just to a great extent regrettably
even among scientists
they have taken the view that science
just because it is characterized by
experimental tests has to be only about
experimental tests but that's a trap
that means if that was so it would mean
that science is only about humans and
not even about humans but about Human
Experience only
it's solipsism it's uh purporting to
have a rigorous objective world view
that only uh observations count and but
it ends up by its own inexorable logic
as saying that only Human Experience is
real which is solipsism
so I think it's uh important to regard
science not as
an Enterprise for the purpose of making
predictions but as an Enterprise for the
purpose of discovering what the world is
really like what is really there how it
behaves and why which is tested by
observation but it is absolutely amazing
that the tiny little access
parochial and and a weak and error-prone
access that we have to observations is
capable of testing so
theories and knowledge of the whole of
reality that has tremendous reach far
beyond our experience and yet we know
about it that's the amazing thing about
science that's the
aspect of science that I want to pursue